[Musique]
allam qui a donné le droit de vote aux
femmes hnc que c'est en 1945 21 octobre
et je ne pourrais pas vous dire qui ma
foi la peau leur famille chez blum
général de gaulle je dirais pétain
peut-être lancement viole mais bon sang
soit rien monsieur
napoléon iii [ __ ] je ne suis pas au
courant parce que j'ai pas de télévision
[Musique]
dans les années 30 les femmes françaises
sont face à un constat est à une
question
inspiré par les suffragettes anglaise
qui ont milité pour le droit de vote en
grande bretagne dès 1903 les femmes
s'unissent et entreprennent des actions
pour faire entendre leur voix lors des
scrutins
liberté égalité femmes de toutes
conditions unissez vous pour conquérir
votre égalité les militantes féministes
américaines sont très satisfaits de leur
journée de revendications pourtant
parfois mouvementés organisée à
l'occasion du 50e anniversaire du droit
de vote pour les femmes aux états unis
en france un personnage s'est démarqué
pour faire avancer cette cause
les journalistes écrivains conférencière
et ethnologue le but de son existence
aura été de servir de grandes causes la
france la paix mais aussi la cause des
femmes louise weiss a toujours été
curieuse des autres attentive à leurs
joies leurs peines en chine en afrique
ou à paris louise weiss a consacré sa
vie à ses causes avec un militantisme
acharné
ah oui absolument acharné parce que non
seulement je pensais aux droits des
femmes mais je pensais que chez les
femmes entrer dans l'arène politique
l'ambiance générale s'améliorait dans le
sens de la paix entre les deux guerres
la france se reconstruit et le rôle des
femmes est devenu déterminant que ce
soit dans l'industrie
la fonction publique où les actions
sociales oui nous étions responsables un
moment là un mineur pour nos droits
comme nous disions majeur pour nos
fautes interdite est incapable devant la
loi chose aucun droit de la citoyenneté
en 1935 alors que les femmes n'ont ni le
droit de vote ni celui de se présenter
elle va alors bravé les interdictions
pour servir la cause les contributions
labeaume a mollo jourdain
nous avions organisé en préfecture
à l'aide sans volonté la pluie ayant
déversé nouvelle opération
l'écu devoir tenir jusqu'au bout une
urne faire voler leurs droits et pour la
défendre
j'ai manier la poudre la poudre de riz
dans le ton est donné
la presse relaie cet événement est petit
à petit l'idée s'immisce dans la
conscience collective
les femmes ont une voix notamment
électorale et moins de dix ans plus tard
et bien mesdames c'est au général de
gaulle que vous devez le droit de vote
le 21 avril 1944 en effet réuni sous sa
présidence à alger le comité français de
libération nationale prenait cette
décision après avis favorable de
l'assemblée consultative le général mais
pas uniquement je pense que la politique
féminine qui a été menée a été
importante dans cette promotion féminine
avec un certain retard sur les pays
voisins
la france vit alors un jour historique
pour la première fois depuis toujours le
coeur de 20 millions de voix
vortex loi nome et moi de voir c'était
le 29 avril 1945 et les bureaux de vote
malgré tout l'appareil sur la nel du
tapis vert de l'isoloir et de l'urne
sont devenus très féminin puisque au
nombre des électeurs s'ajoute pour la
première fois la foule des électrices
elle participe alors massivement fier de
faire partie des premières générations à
jouir de cette prérogative
décidément ce qu'a apporté du nouveau du
nouveau oui mais pas pour tout le monde
vous devez départ et pourquoi pas
jusqu'à présent
merci certaines femmes et c'est bien
leur droit refusent de voter par
habitude ou par désintérêt le rôle des
femmes dans la vie politique reste à
asseoir et même à justifier pour
certains d'accord pour qu'une femme
devienne maire de grimaud
pourquoi pas normand carita si
intelligente ya plein de raisons
moi non la femme a que ce cop à son
ménage vous être de son temps c'est sans
doute ce qui pose le plus de problèmes à
n'importe quelles avancées sociales je
crois que maintenant du fait de légalité
de leurs droits des femmes nouvelles
sont nés et qu'ils ont à aménager les
conquêtes que nous avons fait pour elle
et qui n'y vont pas lentement aménager
les conquêtes ça veut aussi dire aller
de l'avant et prendre des places pour
arriver à une parité
il n'est même pas impensable d'imaginer
que l'une d'elles un jour sera
présidente de la république et c'est en
1974 pour la première fois qu'une femme
se présente à l'élection eh bien oui je
suis une femme et j'ose me présenter
comme candidate à la présidence de cette
république d'hommes le message de louise
weiss a ouvert la voie à des droits
élémentaires qui ont profondément changé
le paysage démocratique français avec
une idée aussi forte que simple je crois
qu'il faut retenir se fie au total
j'évolue que rien de ce qui est humain
ne me soit étranger
[Musique]
pourquoi contre les indes est drôle
c'est sacha crois qu'on parle du mal à
fond dit on est contre les hommes on le
vit vous nous parlez maire de vars l'ex
aussi c'est pas vrai on ne prenait pas
pour les femmes en est absolument
de toute façon la moitié des bonnes
femmes elles vivent avec un bonhomme
donc alors joueur favori serait contre
les gens du salon
sous l'arc de triomphe à paris repose le
soldat inconnu représentant symbolique
des militaires morts pour la france
chaque soir depuis 1923 la flamme qui le
surplombe est ravivée puis un jour un
homme sur deux est une femme peut-on
lire sur des banderoles le 26 70 12
femmes tentent en effet de déposer une
gerbe à plus inconnu que le soldat
inconnu sa femme
du coup on les embarque les journaux en
parlent le mlf est née officiellement
mais une question se pose est-ce que
vous savez ce qu'est le mouvement de
libération de la femme
alors d'abord c'est le mouvement de
libération des femmes et ensuite la fin
c'est qu'ils en ont assez que les maris
commun de toujours oui alors c'est un
peu réducteur moi j'aurais plutôt dit
que p farès manifeste parce qu'un loyer
que les hommes ils sont bénins dans
leurs fauteuils regarde la télé c'est
leur droit
cette prise de conscience collective
alors largement médiatisé est en fait le
produit de groupes plus modestes qui
agissait déjà du fonds d'aidé 1967 avec
une autre femme un petit groupe qui
s'appelait fema et qui étaient mixtes
d'ailleurs et en 70 c'est la collection
des petits groupes qui travaillait dans
leur coin qui s'est réuni pour donner le
mouvement de libération des femmes des
points de départ différent mais des
revendications communes l'égalité hommes
femmes dans le travail et les tâches
domestiques la liberté des femmes à
disposer de leur corps
l'accès libre et gratuit à l'avortement
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et notamment le viol c'est la
guerre des sexes existent ce n'est pas
nous qui l'avons déclaré
qu'est ce que fait le féminisme il en
montre certaines horreurs pour mieux les
dépasser
et pour mieux aller vers un avenir
serein dans un premier temps les
réunions du mlf sont réservés aux femmes
et même si cette mesure se veut
provisoire très vite les hommes veulent
se joindre au mouvement
avec parfois une grosse motivation
pourquoi les jeunes ne contribuait pas
comme les femmes à la libération
or ne peuvent pas participer à la lutte
antiraciste alors ça c'est complètement
con dollars bref les militants du mlf
investissent l'espace publique et
manifeste
elles écrivent et dessine aussi plus
aucun sujet de société n'est abordée
sans que la question des femmes
deviennent centrale mais on ne peut pas
poser la question de l'égalité quand on
reconnaît qu'il ya de sexe différent à
ce moment là il faut dire deux perdent
deux individus équivalent mais comme
tout combat aussi juste soit ils les
militantes sont confrontés à des
oppositions parfois surprenantes à
l'élastique est ce que ça vous faisait à
l'époque d'être défini pardonnez moi
l'expression comme sa love mal baisées
vie rameaux c'est dans l'ordre des
choses groc le féminisme dans ces
manifestations a toujours été
accompagnés de la caricature qu'on en a
fait c'est à dire on nous ne pouvons pas
émergé 50 caricature
s'il est vrai qu'au siècle dernier le
terme virago désigné de manière
péjorative une femme avec des allures
d'homme aujourd'hui préférons lui sa
définition originelle qui désigne une
femme forte et courageuse c'est très
bien parce qu'autrefois on était trop
malheureux et j'espère que les femmes
sont plus heureuses que ma génération
oui c'est notamment en martelant
quelques messages simples que la
condition féminine avance le combat
faisait des féminines peut-être un
combat violent violent au niveau des
idées sans doute pour certains et même
pour certaines qui semble subir le
mouvement comme un véritable affront
actuellement le mlf et qu'une mauvaise
image de marque pour la femme
et lorsque vous arrivez comme moi à me
battre envers un homme est pas la
première réflexion qui vous fait ou
avant pied arrêtés mais laisse la
première mouture
souvent moqué craint ou incompris le mlf
a néanmoins pesé sur toutes les
décisions concernant les femmes ou la
famille plus aucun débat n'a eu lieu
sans une représentante du mlf
au début ça agace mais au final ça
avance et puis il faut quand même
rappeler que ce mouvement via a permis
aux femmes de passer du moyen-âge à
l'art moderne une nouvelle ère
parfaitement résumé par ses jeunes
comédiennes de talent e mail of sunday
existe plus c'est ce machin rouillac des
femmes se fini maintenant
maintenant elles ont obtenu ce qu'elle
voulait l'avortement est libre il ya la
pilule vous croyez que ça survient
quelque chose le madoff
quelle est la qualité que vous préférez
chez une femme la réserve est loin de
s'être réservé quelques années plus tard
les 100 ans du mlf coule toujours dans
les carburateurs de la société en 2003
né le mouvement ni [ __ ] ni soumises
afin d'entreprendre des actions
concrètes contre les violences faites
aux femmes
c'est un mouvement mixte populaire et
féministe j'ai l'impression qu'on a deux
catégories de jeunes femmes une femmes
celles qui se battent pour la parité qui
ya celles qui se battent pour survivre
celle qui habite en citer je pense qu'il
faut encore le répéter que quand une
famille menacée
c'est toute la société qui est menacée
merci le mouvement a pour but de
dénoncer l'insécurité dans les quartiers
mais s'étend rapidement à toutes les
rues et même à l'europe
rencontrant les mêmes oppositions que le
mlf il ya ceux qui veulent pas en
entendre parler qui pense que c'est même
pas la peine parce qu'on est en train de
toucher leurs privilèges aussi et parce
qu'on est en train de faire exploser les
l'omerta et toutes les questions tabous
dans les quartiers en 2008 un autre
mouvement se crée et son ampleur est
désormais mondiale les femen et ses
seins nus lequel lance la bataille pour
le droit des femmes
chaque mouvement apporte une avancée
notable en cassant les codes et les
préjugés de l'époque qui l'a fait naître
pour manifester bien habillé tout
simplement se dévêtir comme ça c'est
pourtant comme ça qu'elle manifeste
comme ça que le monde les connaît et
comme ça qu'elle capte l'attention et
font passer leur message
aujourd'hui
n'écoute pas la parole des femmes ce qui
les hantent à percer le vent des femmes
longue et semée et sans l'a compris on
n'a pas d'autre choix pour ce faire
entraîne donc regardez moi je suis ça
n'a rien de sexuel et le regard des
premières militants du mlf sur les femen
démontre une certaine continuité
idéologique
ici elle voulait rendre hommage à la
femme du soldat inconnu
parmi les manifestantes sur l'image à
droite cathy berne m
quarante ans après elles regardent leur
happening déshabillé de ces jeunes
consoeurs je trouve qu'elles sont bien
ces phénomènes parce que est là pour
faire le buzz unis vont carrément quoi
et elles vivent avec les méthodes
aujourd'hui du mlf au phénomène les
années passent les méthodes évoluent
mais le fonds demeure un des slogans du
mouvement de libération des femmes
c'est notre corps nous appartient le mlf
a créé une dynamique un soulèvement et
même un nîmes
[Musique]
t
aujourd'hui on est en train de
redécouvrir que les femmes sont des
êtres humains et que c'est une femme
c'est pas un trou par lequel le sexe
d'un homme entre et par où les enfants
sorte que les femmes c'est aussi autre
chose
[Musique]
au conseil des ministres du 26 mai 1976
la journaliste et écrivaine françoise
giroud alors secrétaire d'état chargé de
la condition féminine présente sans une
mesure en faveur de l'autonomie et des
droits des femmes
ce projet de 32 pages le voici pour ceux
qui n'ont pas encore la télévision
couleur je précise qu'il est de couleur
orange afin de changer les lois en
profondeur ces mesures prennent en
compte l'ensemble des aspects de la vie
d'une femme de son plus jeune âge à sa
retraite
l'idée c'est de mettre au point une
politique qui aura pour effet de changer
la vie de toutes les femmes françaises
sans pour autant ôter quoi que ce soit
aux hommes savez je suis je suis pour
l'équivalence entre les hommes et les
femmes et pas du tout pour le martyre
des hommes simplement pas pour le
martyre des femmes non plus françoise
giroud présente la liste des réformes à
accomplir en cinq ans destiné à
atteindre ce qu'elle appelle
l'équivalence social alors en gros dans
cinq ans si la situation de la france
est bonne sera bonne pour tout le monde
si elle est mauvaise tout ce que je
demande c'est qu'elle ne soit pas plus
mauvaise pour les femmes que pour les
hommes le but de ces mesures est la
reconnaissance par la société d'une
valeur égale et le libre exercice de
droits et de devoirs égaux et si tout ça
semble clair aujourd'hui dans les années
70 c'était plus compliqué les mentalités
c'est naturellement ce qu'il ya de plus
difficile surtout sur un sujet pareil y
compris les mentalités des ministres
avec les qualifs adecco d'abord et pour
pouvoir changer les lois laissant une
mesure ont été minutieusement préparée
avec l'ensemble des ministères concernés
de l'éducation au travail de la santé
aux finances et de la justice à
l'intérieur tout ça a été étudiée
ministère par ministère
tout ça a été chiffré il ya des choses
qui coûtent très cher y en a d'autres
qui ne coûte pas d'argent et tout ça a
été acceptée par les ministres
intéressés
et voici le plan d'attac éducation et
formation de jeunes filles définition
par un nouveau régime matrimonial légal
des nouvelles responsabilités des jeunes
femmes révision de l'ensemble des
conditions de travail et des freins à la
promotion et à l'égalité des salaires
mais aussi des mesures visant à
faciliter la maternité pour celles qui
le désirent nouvelles conditions du
partage des tâches parentales et
domestiques extension de la prise de
responsabilité sociale des femmes par
une ouverture plus grande des portes de
la vie politique et administre
ti vct ou encore institutions de divers
systèmes d'assurance obligatoire
couvrant aussi bien le loyer que le
décès du chef de famille et contribuer
ainsi à combler les failles et les
insuffisances du système actuel de
protection sociale une autre mesure
consiste à protéger les femmes qui ont
plus de 55 ans enfin françoise giroud
propose une loi générale qui devrait
permettre de sanctionner toutes les
dispositions juridiques discriminatoires
pour ça elle s'avère conciliante et us
d'une grande diplomatie démonstration il
s'agit en somme de définir une politique
pour les femmes qui soit à la fois
respectueux des traditions françaises
parce qu'il ya des choses qui sont
bonnes toujours dans les traditions et
qui en même temps tiennent compte
véritablement des aspirations et des
besoins des jeunes femmes respect des
traditions pour ne pas voir des nuées de
conservateurs se braquer contre les
mesures et accent sur la jeunesse mais
malgré ces efforts les sens une mesure
et françoise giroud trouve tout de même
quelques ennemis
je serai très ennuyé si je n'avais pas
d'ennemis ce serait mauvais signe
mais pour un changement en profondeur
père est né viable il faut un éveil des
consciences des hommes comme des femmes
je crois que tout ça a commencé à
héberger la conscience masculine et ceux
qui a hébergé aussi et dans la
conscience féminine bien sûr et ceux qui
a hébergé c'est l'idée très importante
que les femmes sont des êtres humains
des relativement neuf
elle a existé pendant longtemps mais
elle a disparu au 19e siècle en france
encore d'ailleurs l'éducation des
enfants fait également partie du projet
et là encore elle va faire appel à
l'histoire pour établir des principes
fondamentaux
ils ont qu'il ya une certaine idée de la
division du travail quitte une idée
relativement récente qui est une idée
qui est née dans la société industrielle
la femme et à la main
s'occupe des enfants et l'amener gagne
de l'argent de l'or et le ramène à la
maison et on a complètement déserté la
vieille idée selon laquelle l'homme et
la femme vivait ensemble et s'occuper
ensemble des enfants et je souhaiterais
beaucoup que cette liste soit ranimer et
parmi ces mesures elle entend également
lutter contre le sexisme dans la
fonction publique dans la fonction
publique on est notée on a des critères
n'est ce pas on dit épaules ils arrivent
à l'heure eh bien je voudrais que dans
ses notes interviennent un critère qui
est celui du comportement à l'égard du
personnel de l'autre sexe
ce sera très important trésor les
réforme s'applique aussi bien dans le
domaine professionnel que dans l'espace
public et je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez l'histoire des chasseurs et
du lièvre pour moi la situation se
présente ainsi il ya toujours eu des
chasseurs les avons chassés les femmes
et de même il ya des chasseurs qui vont
dans la forêt et qui chasse les lièvres
tu as fait normal imaginez que
brusquement des lièvres lui de courir se
retourne et dire mieux ceci vous
continuez j'appelle mon avocat mais
c'est ça la situation est alors les
chasseurs 10 mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça mais de quoi se mêlent mails sont
insupportables sont forts ces femmes
laisser le lièvre qui va provoquer ci
avait pas de lien avant dans la forêt je
ne dirais pas dessus sur les sens une
mesure initialement proposé 80 sont
acceptés ce qui ne signifie pas que
chacune fait l'objet d'une loi
l'époque où les mesures sont adoptées
fait que d'autres lois devront s'y
ajouter ultérieurement pour s'adapter
aux besoins sociétaux et aux évolutions
du monde du travail
c'est une tentative d'éliminer toutes
les discriminations qui existe entre les
femmes et les hommes
ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles seront
toutes éliminées il reste les injustices
bien sûr mais enfin je suis là pour
essayer de les réparer et comme elle
l'écrit vie si les femmes ne sont pas
encore ce qu'elles seront ni ce qu'elle
voudrait être
elles ne seront plus jamais ce qu'elle
était
[Musique]
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
[Musique]
au lendemain de la première guerre
mondiale la france doit être repeupler
alors en 1920 les députés uniquement des
hommes trouvent la solution
une loi qui interdit tout bonnement
l'avortement et la contraception 50 ans
et un baby boom plus tard et malgré la
sévérité des peines encourues on
constate que 1920 n'est pas appliquée et
in n'est pas applicable non plus elle
est bafouée et voilà et qui est toujours
mauvais pour un état de conserver dans
sa législation des textes qui sont
inappliqué évidemment tout le monde
n'est pas de cet avis je suis contre
l'avortement parce que l'avortement
c'est un échec et le constat d'un échec
je pense que la vie est une chose belle
je pense que rien est beau comme un
enfant ça c'est l'argument des opposants
et pour les défenseurs du progrès ça
ressemble à ça ce que nous proposons
sont sûrs de nos tours de deux idées
la première c'est évidemment la priorité
à la contraception l'avortement c'est
toujours un pis-aller et nous
considérons que l'avortement doit être
libre parce que le choix de la naissance
est un acte conscient pour nous
respecter la vie ça consiste à choisir
le moment on veut donner la vie un
enfant à l'époque on estime à 300 mille
le nombre de femmes qui se font avorter
chaque année est beaucoup trop en
gardent des séquelles voir perdre la vie
elle est atteinte de septicémie c'est à
dire d'une infection généralisée très
grave et autrefois régulièrement mortel
à la suite d'un avortement mal fait il
faut alors faire comprendre que
l'avortement n'est pas une solution de
confort ou de facilité mais un véritable
enjeu en 1972 a lieu le procès de
bobigny qui est devenu un symbole de ce
débat le procès lui même quelques étés
le jus
man le procès lui-même a marqué un pas
irréversible
michel chevalier est accusé avec trois
autres femmes de s'être rendue complice
de l'avortement de sa fille de 16 ans
enceinte à la suite d'un viol m halimi
réussi à faire acquitter sa cliente pour
la première fois dans l'histoire c'est
formidable les juges ont enfin pris
leurs responsabilités ils ont ils
connaissance et loi qu'elle était plus
applicable
c'est alors une certitude la loi doit
changer et c'est simone veil alors
ministre de la santé qui aura la lourde
charge de présenter le texte de loi
je crois qu'on a oublié aujourd'hui les
jeunes ne savent pas et tant mieux ce
que c'était c'était vraiment un problème
très très très angoissant pour beaucoup
de femmes le débat qui a précédé le vote
de la loi a également été ponctuée par
des attaques violentes parfois même
absolument sordide alors la simone veil
ayant survécu aux camps de concentration
le parallèle était carrément nauséabond
même s'ils sont sortis mais je souhaite
maintenant c'est que ce sont eux qui
sont dégagés et que j'en ai le débat est
alors extrêmement tendu la population
est divisée et tout le monde a un avis
sur la question
même si tout le monde n'est pas concerné
pendant une jeune fille de 16 ans et 17
ans est en salle est ce qu'elle pourrait
se faire avorter ce genre oh non parce
qu'après ça va être
on ne s'en sort plus quoi penser qu'il y
aurait des as oui ce sera là pour tout
et pour tout dire t'as quoi pas à tous
les abus à tous on le dira ah bon on
peut y aller tranquillement puisqu'on
aura toujours la porte de secours ce qui
était tout de même très désagréable dans
le débat c'est la façon dont il a été
alors faussé par des mouvements
d'opinion
à l'extérieur il faut alors faire
comprendre que l'avortement est un
véritable problème qui se doit d'être
dépénaliser pour pouvoir être contrôlés
faire comprendre également les raisons
qui poussent certaines femmes à
interrompre leur grossesse
il n'y a pas encore terminé son service
militaire et je travaille je peux pas
j'ai marié j'ai eu un bébé un petit peu
trop tôt à mon avis est que j'aimerais
en avoir dans deux heures des repas tout
fait tout de suite après midi pour moi
l'avortement parce que une femme
juliette le premier besoin quelques et
l'a6 et de seul avis et c'est de la vie
son corps de temps levées toutes les
traces toutes les marques encore qualité
qui reste sur elle et puis moi quand
j'ai appris que j'étais enceinte c'est
affreux le 5 avril 1971 343 femmes
lancent l'appel des 343 et clame un
million de femmes se font avorter chaque
année je déclare que je suis l'une
d'elles je me demande si cette loi
aurait eu lieu ce n'est pas commencé par
signer le manifeste des 343 après
quelques fois des 343 [ __ ] est
manifeste nous disions que dans notre
vie nous étions toutes faites avortées
pendant que le texte de loi se prépare
le débat devient nationale élus locaux
nous n'acceptons pas ce qui se prépare
visiblement ils sont contre mais pensons
pas que la solution soit les permis
légal de tuer les arguments des anti ivg
ramène souvent le débat autour de la
question de la vie à venir sans prendre
en compte celle de la mère et des
difficultés qu'elle peut rencontrer
comment l'avortement je suis à c'est
absolument incroyable enfin que sont les
hommes qui font les lois parce que s'il
leur arrive est quelquefois d'avoir les
problèmes des femmes et comprendrait
plus facilement qu'il faut absolument ce
problème se règle très très rapide
alors c'est avec autant de finesse que
d'intelligence que simone veil va
présenter son projet à l'assemblée
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
aucune jamais je le dis avec toute ma
conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue ça c'est pour ceux qui
pensent que certaines avortent pour le
fun c'est toujours un drame
cela restera toujours un drame et bien
sûr derrière cette loi il y à des femmes
leur intégrité physique et psychologique
et parfois leur vie actuellement
celles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation de détresse qui s'en préoccupe
puis elle va interroger les opposants à
la loi sur leur jugement face à une
réalité bien plus amère parmi ceux qui
combattent aujourd'hui une éventuelle
modification de la loi répressive
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'il juge comme une faute on suit
manifesté aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et la plus morale dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
la loi veil du 15 janvier 1975 autorise
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
un texte provisoire et votez pour cinq
ans le vote définitif aura lieu en 1979
et les gens ont senti que au delà du
sujet il y avait une femme qui était
seul au lieu de ces hommes qui étaient
une bonne agressivité d'une oppression
d'une tir est d'une vulgarité vis-à-vis
de la femme il avait l'impression que
c'était ont leur arrachait le pouvoir le
pouvoir politique mais aussi on les
atteignait dans l'eure dans leur
virilité dans leur sexualité
aujourd'hui en france il existe toujours
des mouvements qui veulent limiter voire
interdire les vg et l'accès réel des
femmes y est très inégale selon les
territoires et encore sous tendu de bien
trop de jugement au planning familial du
département personne ne décroche et sur
place on trouve porte close
certaines femmes se trouvent donc livrée
à elle-même et manque d'information à
l'international la situation diffère
selon les pays
par exemple l'irlande progresse sur la
question tandis que l'argentine y est
toujours opposée et que l'espagne l'a
récemment remise en cause
nous devons soutenir les femmes pour que
l'avortement le reste accessible la
société quels que soient son
développement économique où le régime
politique qui la gouverne a encore du
mal à concéder aux femmes la liberté de
décider si elles veulent ou non
poursuivre une grossesse à oman
et pour citer simone de beauvoir
n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffira d'une
crise politique économique ou religieuse
pour que les droits des femmes soient
remis en question ces droits ne sont
jamais à qui vous devez rester vigilante
votre vie durant
[Musique]
rentré à 15h30 roland martineau va
s'occuper de son foyer préparer le repas
du soir
évidemment il aurait préféré que sa
femme reste au foyer mais racheter une
maison même à crédit ça coûte cher
[Musique]
depuis 1946 l'égalité professionnelle
est reconnue en droit alors les femmes
étant à l'époque principalement
considérés comme des mères la loi vise à
les protéger au travail pourtant la
constitution proclame que la loi
garantit à la femme dans tous les
domaines des droits égaux à ceux de
l'homme
en 1972 une loi pose le principe de
l'égalité de rémunération pour un même
travail ou un travail de valeur égale
mais concrètement vous était à l'école
jusqu'à l'âge de 14 ans et monique 24
ans j'ai donc ni l'un ni l'autre n'avait
de formation professionnelle de mouloud
et vous retrouver là où d'un certain
temps avec une différence de salaire
oui je ne comprends pas vu que ça allait
bien les femmes
la loi du 4 juillet 1975 interdit de
rédiger une offre d'emploi réservé à un
sexe de refuser une embauche de
licenciés en fonction du sexe ou de la
situation de famille sauf motif légitime
mais la féminisation de certains métiers
a encore un peu de mal à passer trop de
métier n'ont pas encore de féminin
les salines en 1976 la directive
européenne du 9 février introduit la
notion d'égalité de traitement qui vise
à passer d'une égalité formelle à une
égalité réelle
la directive enjoint les états à prendre
des mesures afin de supprimer toutes les
dispositions discriminatoires envers les
femmes est contraire au principe
d'égalité de traitement
retour en france pour une réflexion sur
cette vieille maxime bien bafouée à
travail égal salaire égal
une loi pourtant été voté il ya cinq ans
pour que les salaires des femmes soit au
même niveau que ceux des hommes pour un
travail de même valeur au cours des
années 70-80 la population française
prend progressivement conscience de la
discrimination faite aux femmes en
matière d'égalité professionnelle et
salariale
quels sont ceux où seuls qui gagnent
moins de 650 francs par mois
trois jeunes filles aucun garçon
pourtant de nombreuses mesures ont
permis aux femmes d'avoir un accès à
l'éducation et aux formations
en stage de menuiserie nous former aussi
bien des hommes que des femmes
est ce que vous faites une différence
dans l'enseignement en enseignement non
c'est exactement le même travail que les
petits ponts
où les femmes comme les hommes mais dès
qu'il s'agit de se faire embaucher et
ensuite au niveau de l'emploi il ya une
différence l'emploi on a toujours lieu à
un problème pour placer les jeunes
filles où les jeunes femmes qui
sortaient de chez nous
artisan qui emploie les ouvriers
quittent toujours un peu pour employer
une jeune fan des siècles de
conditionnement ça ne se renverse pas en
deux coups de cuillère à pot
pour vous il n'ya pas de métier au
masculin non comme je pense qu'un n'a
pas fait une
c'est donc au niveau de l'état comme au
niveau de la société que tout ça doit
changer de nouveaux codes et de
nouvelles habitudes à prendre
heureusement les bonnes volontés existe
et depuis votre iphone travail vous vous
êtes mis à faire et clichy ça me vient
c'est dans ce contexte qu'ils vivent et
rudi députée européenne nommée ministre
des droits des femmes impose une loi
pour l'égalité professionnelle qui prend
en compte l'aspect sociétal du problème
c'est à dire que nous vivons dans une
société où seuls ceux reconnus comme
travailleurs les gens qui ont un salaire
ou une entreprise ou qui ont pignon sur
rue c'est à dire que toutes les
situations des femmes qui pour des
raisons diverses qu après tout qui les
regardent ou qui regardent à la famille
puisque la décision est prise en famille
se sont arrêtés d'avoir un travail
salarié peut rester chez elle et se
consacrer à t-elle telle ou telle tâche
les enfants peut-être aidé le mari et
c'est l'extraordinaire injustice c'est
qu'elles deviennent invisibles
elle ne compte plus pour ça elle va même
aller jusqu'à diffuser des spots de
publicité à la télévision non arrêté
dans la vie professionnelle les femmes
en trop d'obstacles à franchir formation
restreint des bouchers nombreux
salaire inégaux ce n'est pas normal ça
doit changer
aujourd'hui encore les hommes touchent
en moyenne 23% de plus que les femmes
chef de l'état avait abordé le problème
dans sa dernière conférence de presse il
avait souligné qu'il s'agissait bien
plus d'un problème de moeurs que de loi
un problème de moeurs qui dure déjà
depuis bien longtemps et qui évolue
lentement très lentement
j'espère bien qu'on ne va pas faire du
ministère des droits de la femme une
institution permanente
non mais il n'y a aucune raison qu'on en
est encore besoin au 21ème siècle
combien faudra-t-il encore d'année pour
expliquer aux femmes leurs droits et aux
hommes leur devoir une étude de l'insee
de mars 2011 montre qu'une personne sur
4 continue à penser qu'en période de
crise économique les hommes devraient
être prioritaires pour trouver un emploi
les femmes conserve aujourd'hui encore
une image de personnes - disponible que
les hommes puisqu'elles doivent
concilier leur vie professionnelle et
leur vie familiale
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne peut
pas pondre qu'on ne peut pas couver
le plus incroyable sans doute fait 7 est
un nom d'animal c'est sa reproduction
les rôles sont inversés la femelle
transmet les oeufs au mal et c'est le
père qui va porter la couvée jusqu'à la
délivrance
[Musique]